welcome my name is boris pascaver
i am a software engineer agile
consultant
online educator and author based in new
york city
and i'm really excited to introduce you
to the pandas
library over the course of the next hour
maybe hour and a half we'll be walking
through a sample
data set seeing what we can do with
pandas
so this is really great for excel people
people who are used to working with
graphical spreadsheet applications like
excel or perhaps google sheets
or numbers um and seeing
how pandas can help expand on those data
analysis operations the
simplest way that i can describe pandas
is excel
on steroids let's take a step back
before we dive into our data set
and talk a little bit about what pandas
is pandas is a
data analysis library it's a toolkit for
data and it's built on top of the python
programming language now the python
language itself is
about 30 years old i think it came out
around 1991
the pandas library itself is about 10
years old
it began as a pet project by a man
named wes mckinney he was working at i
think a hedge fund or some kind of
financial management firm
and he found that it was increasingly
difficult to work with financial data
all the things that we need to do with
data in our everyday data
analysis whether it be identifying
duplicate rows
or cleaning missing values or joining
data sets together
sorting values identifying broken values
working with text data splitting text
data up removing white space
all of these common operations uh that
pretty much comprise the majority of
data analysis the
the part of getting data into the right
shape in order for you to be able to
find the story
from it all those data analysis
operations he found
were not particularly easy in the
solutions available to him so he built
pandas to solve that problem eventually
it became an open source solution lots
of developers came on board started
contributing to it
and now it's a huge data analysis a
library
in fact pandas is so popular today that
it's largely credited for the growth of
the entire
python programming language as a whole
the way trends are going python is on
track to become
the most widely used programming
language in about a year or two
according to things like google search
trends and
most of python's huge growth and
popularity has been attributed to
the role it plays in the data science
ecosystem and pandas many times is
sort of the nucleus of that the
epicenter of that python is popular for
a wide variety of these data
applications whether it be machine
learning
or natural language processing and
pandas is kind of the tool kit that sits
in the middle that allows you to get the
data into the shape that you need it to
be in
for an analysis or to feed it into any
of these additional tools
that you need to work with all right so
let's get into the actual
part of this live stream the heart of
this tutorial we're going to be walking
through a sample
data set i want to introduce you to that
data set right now
so hopefully you can see my screen this
is the jupyter notebook or the
development environment in which we're
going to be writing our code tonight
what's really great about jupiter is it
has this trial and error
approach to writing your code so you can
write any code you want in any of these
cells
you execute it and the notebook gives
you immediate feedback so
as a simple example if i type in one
plus one
and i execute it you can see we're going
to get two below and that's really great
when we're analyzing something like a
data set
because we can try a different snippet
of code see the result
see the output see if it fits what we're
looking for and if not we simply modify
the code
rerun it again there's no need to save
files or to run
python from the terminal we just keep
this kind of ongoing feedback loop going
in order to practice and in the spirit
of being on twitch
uh i've decided that we're going to be
analyzing a video game sales
data set so this data set is taken
directly from kaggle.com
if you're unfamiliar with kaggle kaggle
is a really great site for finding
all sorts of different data sets uh
in addition to the actual data sets
themselves you're going to find people's
analyses of them so
if you if you'd like to explore how
other people think about a problem it's
a really great
place to start and as i scroll here you
can see all kinds of great
data sets are available all space
missions from 1957
heart failure prediction women's
international football results top
chess players there's all kinds of these
great statistics some of them are
totally random some of them are
public government statistics all kinds
of great stuff and in the spirit of
being on twitch
i searched for a video game data set and
i found this video game
sales data set right here from gregory
smith
and that's what we're going to be
working with and analyzing all right
so i have my jupyter notebook right here
and it's
in the exact same folder as my csv
file my comma separated values text file
that's storing
my actual data so let's begin by
importing pandas
and simply importing this data set this
plain text
into a pandas data structure and if
anybody watching here is more of an
excel person who
doesn't have a lot of familiarity with
python or programming don't worry i'm
going to try to keep things as
non-technical as possible just giving
you a big picture overview of what's
going on here
all right so in here in my jupiter
notebook
i'm going to begin by importing my
pandas library there's a wide variety of
python libraries there's hundreds of
thousands of them
i want to specify that i want to use
pandas so i'm going to import pandas
and i'm going to assign it a popular
alias and alias is just an
alternate name we give to a library so
we don't have to write out the full name
later on pandas is six letters it's a
lot to type
people make mistakes so we commonly give
it the alias of pd
so here i'm going to write import pandas
as pd and once i
execute the cell pandas is imported and
i can reference all of its available
functionalities straight
through pd so let's begin by
showing you how we can import a data set
pandas actually supports a wide variety
of file types that it can import
i'm just going to show you a list here
of all that is possible
let's see here if i can get my
autocomplete to show up
see here one more time
pd.read
okay it looks like my autocomplete
functionality is off but pandas has
support for data sets like csvs tsv's
excel files um json
javascript object notation sql files
hdf files it can even take
things that you've copied in your
clipboard and import them into a pandas
data structure etc
it supports a wide variety of file types
and it can also
save or export to a wide variety of file
types as well
so here the method i'm looking for the
functionality that i'm trying to use
here is called read csv
which reads a csv file into pandas and
our file in the same directory is called
vgsales.csv so i'm going to execute that
scroll up
and we're going to be exposed to our
very first pandas
data structure or our very first object
so for those who are not programmers
when i use the word
object all i'm simply referring to is
this digital container
of data it's a specific data structure
that is optimized
for storing some type of data in some
type of format
so the data frame which we see here this
visual output
is effectively the equivalent of an
excel grid
or an excel table it's a two-dimensional
table
of data so it has rows and it has
columns okay so the reason it's
two-dimensional when i use that term
all that two-dimensional means is that
there are two points of reference that
are required
in order to extract any single point
from the table
so for example let's say i wanted to get
this value right here in the genre
column of
role playing how can i extract this
specific value
well i can't simply say use the genre
column because there's
a ton of values in this column there's
actually 16
598 values in this column alone so
simply giving me the column
giving me one reference point is not
enough
similarly if i were to say give me the
value from row four
well row four is not enough of an
identifier either because there's a lot
of values in row four
rank name platform year etc so in order
to get role playing here i need the
intersection of the row
and the column so because i need two
points of reference
it is a two dimensional data set that's
all that we mean when we talk about
dimensions
it's how many points of reference we
need to extract any point
so if you have a single column of data
it can be called a one-dimensional
data structure because you only need one
point of reference the
row number in order to extract any value
all right the number of rows and
the number of columns is irrelevant if
we have a million rows and a million
columns it's still a two-dimensional
data set
all right let's take a quick look at
what we have in this data set we have
the name of the video game we have the
rank
it has on the list and it looks like in
general this data set is sorted by the
total number
of global sales or millions of copies
that this video game has sold
worldwide so it looks like wii sports
has sold 82.7
million copies we can see a breakdown by
region so north america
europe japan and other countries and for
each
video game we also have the platform or
the console that it was released for
the year of release which you'll notice
is going to have
floating point values notice that this
is fundamentally a year of 2006
but it's stored as 26.0 we'll talk about
why that is a little bit later
we also have a genre of uh the type of
game the category
as well as the publisher so in this case
nintendo all right
so once i see this data set i can decide
to
modify it uh modify its import
manipulate it
etc so let's talk a little bit about
these numbers we see on the
hand side here this is what's called the
index
and the index is basically an identifier
for each
row so if we don't specify any of our
columns
to serve as the index pandas will
generate an automatic
numeric index starting from zero
so here you can see the first row is
assigned an index of zero
the second row is assigned an index of
one all the way to the end of the data
set
it's just some kind of identifier that
can be used to
mark a row so pandas is actually pretty
flexible
in that the index can be set to be any
type of data type at all
so we can have our index or our
identifier free trow
be a piece of text it can be a number it
can be a floating point
it doesn't even have to be unique so our
index
values here or our index labels as
they're sometimes called
can contain duplicates ideally though
it's really great if the index does not
contain
duplicates and it's also really ideal if
it's sorted
in some kind of order ascending or
descending
in general whenever you have a
collection of data that is sorted
there's a lot of optimizations you can
apply to make extraction
a lot easier compared to if it's
unsorted
a good example is something like a
dictionary in real life the
reason that it's really easy to find a
word in a dictionary is because it's
ordered because you can
cut the result set very quickly by
simply moving in the right direction
it's the same idea here
so in general it's a good idea to keep a
sorted index
and in general i would say even though
pandas allows it it's generally a good
idea to have an index that
is unique as well so we have a rank
column that i think would serve as a
really good alternative index because
it's basically serving the same purpose
as the automatically generated index
it's just a
identifier for each row it's a unique
identifier for each video game
so the way that i can set this rank
column to be my index is by providing an
additional parameter here to my read csv
method
a parameter is just a customization
setting it's some kind of
option that i'm altering here and all
i'm going to say here is i want to use
the rank
so now we're going to re-import the csv
and you're going to see it's going to
set the rank column now
as the index so i'm happy with this
result
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take this result which is a data
structure it's called the data frame in
pandas land
and i'm going to assign it to a variable
called sales a variable is just a name
given to some kind of data structure in
our program once it's assigned a name
i can have a reference point for it so
now we we're not just referencing the
csv we've taken its contents
we've loaded it into a data structure
that is saved in memory in our program
and we can reference sales in any of
these cells and we can see the exact
same data structure
that we previously saw and we could
continue to perform all kinds of
operations calculations
uh things on it as well all right so
let's talk a little bit about
attributes and methods an attribute is a
characteristic
or a detail that is available on an
object it's something you can ask the
object about its internal state
its makeup its characteristic so for
example
there is an attribute called d types
that is short for data types and that's
going to tell me the data type
of every column so what i'm going to get
here is actually a different pandas
data structure that we'll talk about in
a in a little while it's called the
series
but basically what we're seeing here is
the column names on the left hand side
you can see
name platform year come from our
original sales data frame
and here we can see their data types
it's important to note that in pandas
object means text or a string
in programming terms so the name and
platform columns for example are holding
text values so your columns
ideally should hold homogeneous values
what that means is they should be of the
same
data type it doesn't matter what that
data type is
numbers integers floats strings booleans
dates
as long as it's consistent if your
column holds
different data types it's usually an
indicator that you're trying to store
too many things in that single column
so here we can see the remainder of the
columns are floats which means they are
numbers that have
floating point components all right so
that's an example of an attribute
we just access it using this syntax of
placing a dot followed by the attribute
name
let's now take a look at the complement
to attributes which are
methods a method is a command or a
behavior
that you can give to a data structure to
an object
so for example what i can do is preview
the first couple rows from the beginning
of my data frame using a method called
head you can think of head as being at
the top of the body in a similar sense
we're looking at the top of the data
frame
so i'm going to write the method name
after dot with parentheses and we're
going to get the first
five rows of the data frame by default
now if i click into here and i hold my
shift key and press tab you're going to
see
that we have something called a
parameter a parameter again is a
configuration
setting or an option we used one above
when we for example provided index call
right here
and specifies the number of rows that
should be returned
and by default it has a value of five so
this syntax right here
is equivalent to me actually feeding in
five directly
or equivalent to me writing out the
parameter name the option name of n
and explicitly assigning it a value of
five so these three
pieces of code in the cell are identical
as far as what they return
but of course the benefit of n is that
we can customize it so for example if we
want to see the first
10 rows instead of the first five we
simply modify that
and we get the first 10 rows of the data
set instead
of the first five there is a
complementary method to head
called tail it does the inverse it
returns the last couple rows of the data
frame
so for example if i invoke the tail
method and it also has an end parameter
that also has a default value of 5
if i don't explicitly provide a value
it's going to fall back on 5
and give me the last 5 rows of that
data frame of that table and if i
customize it like something like n
equals let's say eight i'm going to get
the last
eight rows of this data frame
all right all right let's move on to our
first kind of data analysis-like
operation
which is going to be sorting values let
me take a quick second to take a sip of
delicious water
all right so let's take a look at what
we're working with with right here in
sales
here's a preview and as we mentioned
earlier the
video games are sorted in order of their
sales from
the greatest sold to the least sold
let's say i'm curious
to sort this video game a list to this
video game data frame
in alphabetical order so i want to sort
it by the values in this
name column so there is a method
available on a data frame called sort
values
it's going to be invoked in the exact
same way that we just used the head
method above so
we write the method name out it's just
an operation it's a behavior it's
something we can
tell the object to do i want you to sort
your values
and the first parameter we provide here
can be the name of the column that we'd
like to sort by
so here in double quotes because it's a
piece of text
i'm going to tell pandas that i want to
sort this data frame
by the values in the name column so when
i execute this i'm going to get a brand
new data frame
and you're going to see it's going to be
sorted in alphabetical order ascending
and when it's sorting text
alphabetically numbers come first in
fact i think this little
apostrophe comes even before anything
else so you can see it's going to start
with numbers it's actually going to
proceed uh all the way past the symbols
here we have dot and here towards the
end of the
data frame you can start seeing we're
getting to the u's and the w's and even
these
these characters right here so it's
sorted in alphabetical order
so it's what's called an ascending sort
and that is specified by a parameter
here called
ascending which is set to true by
default all right
so this syntax right here is equivalent
to this syntax right here
it produces the same result we can
customize this so for example if we want
to sort
the values in the name column but do it
in descending order from the
end of the alphabet to the beginning we
can customize
and modify this argument from true to
false
so now we're going to get a new data
frame sorted in descending order
the end of the alphabet all the way to
the start of the alphabet all right
here's another example let's say i want
to sort
the values in this data frame by the
platform by the actual
video game console that it came on came
out on it's as simple as just using the
same method but providing it a different
input
we now want to sort by platform and
we're going to see here
we're going to start with the 2600s and
move up or down
to the xbox one all right a couple
important things to note here that
weren't mentioned earlier
this is a pretty big collection of data
we have almost 17 000 rows by 10 columns
so what pandas is actually doing here
is showing us the first five rows then
truncating or
leaving out the middle and then showing
us the last
five rows as well all right now the cool
thing is each one of these
methods that we've called so far
produces a brand new data frame
object and that data frame object is
going to have the same
family or collection of attributes and
methods
as any other data frame they're all the
same fundamental
data type they're the same data
structure they can support the same
types of operations
so i'm getting a data frame here which
means i can go ahead and do something
like call
the head method on the resulting data
frame
and get the first five rows of the
resulting data frame
that is sorted by the platform values in
ascending order all right that's kind of
a
kind of how you start chaining along
these operations to very quickly
iterate and very quickly discover
whether you're moving in the right
direction as far as
is this method returning what i want is
it in the right shape okay let me edit
it
let me add on another method let me keep
moving it iteratively step by step
towards the analysis that i want and
that's one of the benefits as well of
jupiter notebook is we have a complete
record here if we choose to leave it
of all the steps we took to analyze the
data set so not
so unlike excel where you kind of open
it up and you're just left with this
blank table of values with no context
i hear there's a story to be told and in
the context of the jupiter notebook
environment
you can also do things like leave
comments leave images
leave videos leave audio you can even
have
interactive diagrams you know where you
can slide a scale
and see something change on the page
there's all kinds of interactive widgets
that are integrated
so your notebook becomes a story it
becomes an explanation and an analysis
more than just a you know piece of
columns and rows data
just lumped on the screen all right so
we now know how to sort by a single
column what if we wanted to sort
by two columns so for example what if i
wanted to sort
first by the values in the platform
column
and then by the values in the global
sales column
so what i'm saying is i want to sort by
these platforms first i want to go
for you know 2600 first but within
a value of 2600 for all video games that
fall
within that platform within that higher
level
level tier for those video games i want
to sort them by global sales
and i want that process to repeat for
every single platform
in the platform column so what we can do
here
is called the sort values method and now
instead of providing a single
piece of text a single string i'm going
to provide a list
which is marked with square brackets in
python and i'm going to specify the
columns
that i want to sort by so first i want
to sort by platform and then after
comma i'll say that i then want to sort
by global
sales all right so
this by default is going to sort
everything in ascending order
so first up the platform column is going
to be sorted in ascending order so we're
going to see 2600
which is the num the number uh numbers
come before text
when sorting alphabetically and then
within each platform you're going to see
we're going to sort by global sales in
ascending order
so our very first game of super baseball
has the smallest amount of global sales
within my platform of 2600. you can see
here the values start to
incre increase for the platform of 2600
and similarly if we go down here you can
see for my xbox one platform
the numbers here are increasing as well
so we've sorted by
two columns okay
so let's say we take this syntax and we
again modify the ascending parameter
which we saw
we provided a value of false so what
that is going to do is it's going to
sort
both of those columns but now in
descending order
so how is this going to work well first
up it's going to sort the platform
column in reverse alphabetical order
so x1 comes first and then within each
platform such as xbox one
it's going to sort the global sales
column in descending order as well
so now you can see we're going to
decrease from 7.3
to 5.1.3 etc and that process is going
to repeat
for every value we have in the platform
column
all right so that's a consistent sort
order either
everything is ascending or everything is
descending what if we want to do a
different one
for example what if i want to sort my
platform column
in ascending order alphabetically but i
then within it want to sort my global
sales column
in descending order i want those numbers
going down
in other words i want to identify the
highest sales
per platform first so here's what i can
do
i can copy this code we're still sorting
by two columns but now to ascending i'm
also going to pass
a list in square brackets and here i'm
going to provide
booleans or in other words trues and
falses and each one of these is going to
correspond
to the respective value in this list
right here
so first up how do i want to sort
platform if i want to do it in ascending
order i'll provide a true
next up how do i want to sort global
sales i want it descending
so that's the opposite of ascending so
false
and now when i execute this we're going
to get a new data frame
once again the platform is going to be
sorted in ascending order
starting from the beginning beginning of
the alphabet and moving up
and then within each platform the global
sales column
is going to be sorted in descending
order so it's going down
all right and you can use the syntax to
sort as many columns
as you want all right
let's next talk about the in place
parameter
so whenever we have done any of these
methods so far whether it was sort
values or head or tail
each time pandas has made a copy of a
data frame and then done the operations
and given us the copy
so our original sales data frame is in
no way
impacted the data as it came in from our
csv
is still stored in sales nothing has
been modified or lost or manipulated
we've simply created copies each time
we've called these methods well what if
we want to make one of these changes
permanent
well one option is to simply assign
these resulting
values to their own respective variables
much like sales we can sort
we can call this something like platform
sorted sales or something like that
but if we want to modify our original
data frame
our original table our original data
structure there is a parameter available
on a lot of pandas methods called
in place it's going to modify the
existing data structure in place
so what i'm going to do is actually copy
this code from above
and all i'm going to do is add an
additional parameter here an additional
customization
setting called in place and i'm going to
set it to a value of true
so when i execute this we're not
actually going to get any output below
the cell
but if i now check sales
you're going to see we've modified the
original sales data frame
we've now have the platform column
sorted first
followed by global sales so
we have made that change permanent and
so for a lot of methods and pandas
they're going to support the in-place
operation if you want to make that
operation permanent
if you want to keep the work that you
are going to create
as a result of using this method using
this behavior
telling the object to perform this kind
of step-by-step procedure of some sort
sort yourself or give me this collection
of values or
remove this row in place make sure that
those changes are permanent sometimes
you want them to be permanent sometimes
you don't
right so it depends on what you're
trying to do all right
next up let's talk about sorting the
index
i'm going to once again preview the
first five rows of my data frame with my
head method and i'm also going to take
another
much needed water sip
okay so the index as we talked about
earlier
is this collection of labels on the left
hand side they're highlighted in both
they're effectively an identifier for
each
row and we can actually access these
rows
these um you know records in our table
either by the index label
which in this case is a number but it
can be anything else it can be something
like the video game name
or we can access it by the index
position the order that the row
occupies among all the rows
so let's move on to our next problem we
we started out with our data frame
sorted by the index which was the rank
column which was
the rank of the video games in terms of
their total sales and now that's been
completely jumbled up
because we sorted it by platform and by
global sales and made that operation
permanent so how can i sort the index
how can i sort this rank
back to its original shape well just
like there's a sort values method there
is a sort
index method so i'm going to invoke it
and you can see right here it's going to
give me the data frames rows sorted by
the values here
in the index all right once again by
default it's going to be in ascending
order
so for a number or a collection of
numbers it's going to start at the
lowest number
and proceed to the greatest one that is
set of course by a parameter called
ascending the exact same name as we give
to the sort values method
so ascending here equal to true gives us
the exact same result as being invoked
by itself
if we want to sort the index in reverse
order in descending
we can do it like so and it's going to
proceed from the
greatest to the smallest
all right so what i want to do is get us
back into our original shape so what i'm
going to do
is do an ascending equals true
and just like sort values sort index
also has an in place parameter we can
see it right here
so i'm going to provide that an argument
or a setting of true
so now when i take a look at sales we
can see it's back in its original shape
the way that it came in imported from
the csv so nothing is ever lost as long
as you you know
you don't delete columns if you sort in
one direction it's easy to sort back in
any other direction
all right next up let's talk a little
bit about
optimization some small optimizations we
can do
for this data set so there is a helpful
method called
info which is going to give us a nice
summary
of the data frame as a whole we're going
to be able to see how many
total rows there are we're going to see
the number of columns and for each
column we're going to be told the data
type
as well as how many non-null values
that it has so this is our first
introduction to the idea of
nullness so there are going to be
circumstances in real life data
where data is going to be missing where
there simply is no value provided for
a given intersection of a row and a
column in the csv file it can
literally just be two commas in a row
there's just no value provided
so we haven't seen any of this yet in
our data set but pandas is going to
place a specific designation in any cell
where there is a missing value and that
is called n-a-n it's going to look like
this
it's just going to be a capital n
lowercase a capital n
that is short for not a number and
that's basically a fancy way of saying i
don't have a value to put in the cell
so i'm going to plop this thing here
this missing value this absent value is
sometimes called the null
value null just means not present not
absent uh
not visible not known right
so what we're being told here is how
many present
values we have how many non-null values
we have
so for example if we have 16 598 rows
and we have 16 598
non-null values in the name column that
means there are no
missing values in the name column all of
them are present
in comparison if we look at year you can
see here
that we we only have 16 327.
so something like 260 or so year values
are missing they just weren't in the
original data set
so due to technical design
decisions and how panda stores data
internally
in order to support storing these
missing values pandas will convert
columns that store integer values or
whole numbers in other words
into floating points so if we were to
open our actual csv file we would find
that year is storing its years normally
so if i just output the first five rows
of sales below
if we were to open the csv not in pandas
but just
in a plain you know text file we'd see
that the data set is storing 2006
it's pandas that converts this to 2006.0
because it needs a floating point
decimal number in order to support
the missing values in the year comma
they exist somewhere here they're not in
the first five rows obviously
but somewhere down here they exist so
that's the reason why there are decimals
and helping to convert
to the simplest data type is usually a
good idea so ideally what we want to do
is convert
this year column to be an integer all
right
in order to convert it to be an integer
we're going to need to find a way to
deal with those
missing values because pandas is not
going to be able to convert those
missing values to integers
it doesn't know what those values are so
what i propose we do
is get rid of any rows that have
a missing value or this nan value
in the year column all right
before we proceed there i also want to
show you one last thing from this output
from the info method we can see the
memory usage which basically means how
much
space this data frame is storing
on your computer how much your computer
is storing in memory
1.4 megabytes is not a lot but the key
takeaway here is the relative
gains that you make by performing
certain optimizations so
if we can for example remove the
floating point component
from these years and turn them into
whole numbers we can reduce some of the
memory storage and i'll show you i'll
show you some additional tricks
for optimization um that we can do in
just a few minutes
but the important thing to keep note of
here is not the total
number here but the relative percentage
reduction
how much are we reducing because if we
reduce this down to something like 1.0
that might not seem like a lot but that
is close to a 33
decrease so if you're dealing with a
data set that is 2 gigabytes
instead of 1.4 megabytes a 33 reduction
is
pretty staggering so the important thing
is the relative decrease
versus the actual number itself we
shouldn't worry too much about that
okay so the method i want to invoke here
is called drop n a
just like the name suggests is going to
drop or remove
n a values now we can provide here a
parameter called
subset and subset accepts a list
representing the columns that i want to
target so these are the columns in which
pandas is going to look for null values
and if that column has null values the
entire row
that has that null value will be removed
so i'm going to
for example provide year here that's the
column that i want to look for
and we're going to get this data frame
so notice that if i want to find out how
many rows are in my data frame i can
scroll back up here
we can see we have 16 598
but in this return data frame we have 16
327.
that makes sense those are all the rows
that have a valid year
okay so i like what what i have here i
like the fact that my rows with a null
value in the year column have been
removed
so i'm going to keep these changes and
provide the familiar in place equals
true parameter
so now those changes are permanent and i
have my shortened
data frame all right so now what i can
do is convert
this column from a floating point column
to
an integer column it's a lot easier to
convert now because there are no missing
values
and pandas is not going to get confused
so let's talk a little bit about how we
can reference a column
the way we do so is we reference our
data frame we provide
a pair of square brackets and then in
quotes because it's a string it's a
piece of text
we provide the name of the column so i
want to target year in this example
and we're going to pull out just this
column notice that the
index from the data frame will also be
kept
right here right so we see one two three
four five that's coming from rank right
here
and then right here we see only the
values from the year
column okay now
this output that we're seeing here is a
different
pandas data structure it is called a
series
object a series is basically a
one-dimensional
labeled array all right so basically the
simplest way to think about it is
if a data frame is a table if it's a
collection of rows and columns
then a series is just one column
right it's a one-dimensional data
structure because it only needs one
point of reference
it either needs a index label or an
index position
in order to identify any given value
okay on this series there is a method
available called
as type as type is going to convert the
values in here
from one type to another right now it's
a floating point number
but i can provide an argument here of
int that is short for integer
and i'm going to get back a brand new
series where all of my years are now
stored as integers
now simply doing this does not modify
the year column that's being stored
within my data frame so what i actually
need to do is to
overwrite it the way i do this is i'm
going to copy this code
this reference to my column i'm going to
put it on the left hand side and then
provide
an equal sign the easiest way to not get
confused about this
is to always remember that what happens
on the right hand side
takes place first so pandas is going to
reference my sales data frame
it's going to take the year column it's
going to convert the values in there to
an integer once it gets this brand new
column or this brand new series of
integer values
it's then going to overwrite the
existing year column
in the sales data frame so we don't even
need anything like an in-place parameter
we are manually overwriting that column
so when i execute this we're going to
see now
that sales is going to have a year
column
of integers and hopefully that's going
to reduce some of our
data usage it may it may not looks like
it hasn't right now but we can see that
the data type has been reduced to an
integer
versus a float which is generally a step
in the right direction
all right quick break here let's see
here
all right let me take another sip let's
see what we're talking about
next
okay let's talk about one more
optimization that we can do for this
data set
there is a special type available in
pandas called
category category is really great
when you have a column with a limited
set of
unique values so for example a good
example in real life might be gender
or blood type or maybe state of
residence in the united states so
if you have a data set with a million
different rows
but within a state column you only have
50 unique values whenever you have that
kind of condition where
there's a lot of data but a very small
number of
unique values that column is a great
candidate
for becoming a category column what
pandas basically does behind the scenes
with a category column
is rather than duplicating all of the
text values it just keeps one copy of
each
and makes every cell reference reference
that one copy
of any given unique value all right
so there is a method available on a data
frame called
n unique that is called that is short
for number of
unique so what we're actually going to
get here is a series
where once again our index here our
labels our identifiers are going to be
the original
column names from sales these things
right here
and then the values are going to be the
number of unique
values within a given column so what
this tells us
in among what this tells us is among
these 11 000 rows or so
there are only 31 unique values for the
platform
and only 12 unique values for the
category
so i would argue that these two columns
platform and genre
are really good candidates for being
category columns
what would be a really bad idea
something like name
right because every single value is
unique uh every single value
in every single row is unique but
whenever we have a really small number
of unique values
in a column it's really great for making
a category
so here's what we're going to do we're
once again going to reference sales
we're going to extract our column
in this case we're going to use square
brackets again we're going to get
platform
we're once again going to use the as
type method and this time around i'm
going to provide
a string and i'm going to say category
that's going to create a brand new
series for us you can see here it's
going to have 31 different
categories available such as dc xbox 360
wii u etc
and of course what i want to do is
overwrite the platform column so i'm
going to copy
the reference to the column right here
and overwrite it with this brand new one
there we go and i'm going to repeat the
exact same logic for
my genre column so sales genre
is equal to the genre column as type
category
all right so at this point i think it's
a good idea to take a look at our info
method again and we can compare the
before and after so if i scroll up
we can see when i started out we only
had where we had
1.4 megabytes of data and now we have
1.2 which may not sound like a lot right
that only
is a 15 reduction but
remember that is a pretty good chunk of
memory
uh if you're if you're considering a
really large data set if you are talking
about a gigabyte data set that's 150
megabytes that you just shaved off of
memory
so don't worry so much about the size
worry about the relative improvements
many times i've seen operations like
this optimization operations
that have reduced the data frame memory
size by close to 50 percent
right so before we start any kind of
analysis in order to speed up the
process
by which pandas can work it's really
great to look for optimizations like
this converting
floating point columns to integers if
necessary converting columns to
categories
converting text data into date times if
you're working with date time values
it's a good idea to convert them to
actual date objects that are going to
have their own set of methods for
working with dates and times on them
so there's a lot of these optimizations
that we can do before we even start
getting to the analysis all right
so
we are about 45 minutes in and i think
this is going to take roughly 75 maybe
90 minutes we're going to just keep
going and i'm going to cover as much as
i can
within these 90 minutes but since this
is our midway point
i thought it'd be a great idea to just
tell you that
if you really want to dive into this in
more depth
uh if you want me to slow down and
actually talk you through these examples
with
a little bit more patience a little bit
more grace a little bit more depth
there are two options that i can
shamelessly recommend to you
uh shameless self-promotion the first is
a book called
pandas in action of which i am the
author it is published by manning which
is the twitch
channel that you are currently on it is
currently being written so it's about 80
done it's going to be available in print
form uh
early next year early in 2021 but it's
available live
online at manning.com and you can get
basically as much of the book as i've
written so far
and you'll get every new chapter as it's
published so you can actually play a
role in shaping how the book is written
you can offer
your recommendations say i need more of
this covered
i'd like to see more of this method
explored i'd like to see a greater
variety in data sets you can even fix
typos
so it's an ongoing process and
everybody's welcome to collaborate and
help
write and improve the book so you would
get
an early access version of the book and
then you can get the full version either
as a digital version or as a printed
book
when it comes out so just for today
manning
is running a special promotion it's
called the deal of the day and you can
find it at manning.com
dotd deal of the day and you can pick up
the book for something like 40 or 50
off looks like here it's 50 off so huge
savings on the book
if you are a textual learner and you
prefer to read a lot it's a
pretty big book i think right now it's
about 400 pages it's on pace to be about
500
so if you are interested in continuing
your exploration of pandas in a lot
greater depth
uh with lots of examples lots of data
sets a lot more repetition
uh you can check out pandas in action
from manning
it's available again at manning.com
d-o-t-d
for the next couple hours it's available
at 50 off otherwise you can head to
manning.com
and simply search for it right here to
find the book
if you are more of a video person if you
like more comprehensive courses that you
can watch in your browser
i'd also have a pandas course available
on udemy
udemy.com if you're not familiar udemy
is a platform where instructors can sell
courses on any topic whatsoever
programming knitting history music
theory you name it it's here
so i have a 20 hour pandas course it's
called
data analysis with pandas and python i
actually released it about four years
ago but i'm continually releasing new
updates for it
so if you want content like the one
you're watching now where you can
sort of see me code alongside you work
through a sample data set
and also take you through the beginnings
or the basics of the python language
kind of give you more baby steps
especially if you're an excel developer
or an excel person who doesn't have a
lot of experience with python or
programming in general
this course and the book as well we'll
walk you through that with a lot
more baby steps right right now we only
have an hour so i'm kind of moving at
a quick clip but whether you prefer
video or whether you prefer text there
is something for you
uh on udemy.com or on manning.com
related to pandas all right
let's get back to our analysis here
let's get back to some of the operations
we can do with pandas
let's see here let's talk about
selecting columns so
i'm going to add a new header here
called selecting columns
so we saw earlier that we can select a
column
with square brackets so for example if i
want to target publisher
i can do that like so and that's going
to give me a series object a
column of data if i want to target more
than one column i can still provide my
square brackets but inside
i provide a list so it's actually two
pairs of square brackets in a row
and inside the internal list i can
provide
more than one column that i'd like to
extract so for example i may want to go
for publisher
as well as name and because pandas needs
to represent two columns here
it's actually going to give me a data
frame so now we've
kind of created this subset this slice
this copy of our original
10 column data frame we've just taken
two of those columns
and kind of moved them out to a smaller
one in case you ever want to
you know limit the scope of your
analysis
you can do something like that all right
let's see what else we can talk about
let's take a look at sales again
so we also talked about the idea of
indexes right right now our index this
collection of values on the left hand
side is our rank column
let's say instead of this what i wanted
to do is to make it my
name column so i want each rows
identifier to be the name of the video
game
rather than its rank so before i can
actually move this column
in order to preserve this rank
what i need to do is call a method
called reset index
what that is going to do is move my
current index my rank
back into the main data frame here it is
as a column
and pandas is once again going to
generate the standard numeric index
so i'm happy with this i'm going to keep
it by providing in place equals true
and now what i can do with sales is call
a method
on it called set index so as a reminder
we set our first index with the index
call parameter whenever we imported our
csv
now we can arbitrarily choose any column
or even multiple columns to set us
a new index so what i want to do now is
set my name column as the index
so now you can see the names of the
video games are going to appear in bold
right here and if i want to make this
operation permanent
once again i can do in place equals true
and so now we're going to have a new
sales data frame or rather a mutated
modified sales data frame
with the video games name with the video
game names as labels
alright as always before we start any
kind of extraction it's a really good
idea to sort the index
it doesn't really matter whether it's
ascending or descending as long as it's
sorted otherwise it's going to be in
this ramble
random jumbled order and it's harder for
pandas to find any kind of value
or perform any kind of operation more
efficiently so i'm going to call
a the the sort index method which we
talked about previously
as always what i'm doing in jupyter
notebook is i'm previewing my result
i'm making sure it's what i want and if
it is what i want in this case it is
then i provide my in-place parameter and
make that operation
permanent
all right next up let's talk about one
of my favorite
series methods available in pandas it's
called the value
counts method so here's a little bit of
data analysis here's where we're
actually getting to some kind
of insight so we can imagine that this
is a list of video game sales
i don't know for the last 20 years so
maybe it is like a definitive data set
and what if i was curious which genre
was the most represented on this list
so what i'd like to do is count the
occurrence of every value in my genre
column
how many values of sports do i have how
many values of platform do i have
how many role-playing games do i have
etc so what i can do here
is start by referencing my data frame of
sales then reference
my given column let's say genre in this
case there it is there is my series
and on the series i can call a method
called value
counts value underscore counts it's
going to give me a
count of each unique value
so what i'm actually going to get back
here is a brand new series
the index labels in this series are
going to be the
original genres from right here so we
have each value represented once
action sports miscellaneous etc and
here's the count
of those values so we can see here that
action games are the most popular or at
least the most represented
in this data set if i recall correctly
there's also i think it's this parameter
called normalize
if i provide normalize a value of true
what it's going to give me is relative
percentages so it's going to tell me
that
action is 0.199 or roughly 20
of all of the rows in this
in this series and similarly sports is
roughly 14
all right so this is a good opportunity
to talk about broadcasting operations
so we can actually apply an automatic
mathematical calculation to every value
in a column such as this one so in this
case if i wanted this to be written as
percents i'd obviously want to multiply
each value here
by a hundred all right now if you're
familiar with python
you know that the asterisk is the
multiplication operator for example here
i'll multiply
three by five with the asterisk and i'll
get 15.
so you might be surprised that in pandas
it's going to be a syntax that is as
simple as this
i'm simply going to put an asterisk and
then the number i want to multiply by
in this case it's going to be 100 and
i'm going to get back the series
with my percentages now 19
so a lot of people especially new
developers are confused by this because
they say
but you have this pandas data structure
you have the series and you're
multiplying it by a hundred
how can you multiply a number by a table
right
but pandas is really smart it has a lot
of these built-in optimizations
and these kind of shortcuts in coding
where pandas understands what you're
trying to do it understands that you're
trying to multiply
every value in that given column
with by a hundred by the same value and
the same rules apply if we want to do
for example addition
let me just copy this below uh let me
for example say we extract let's say
global sales so if i extract global
sales
there's my column if i want to add let's
say 1.5
to every value in the series it's as
simple as a plus sign
there you go and here's a subtraction
there you go multiplication division uh
any of those common mathematical
arithmetic operations are very easily
applied to every value
in a series with syntax that is as
simple
as this all right let's
take a look next at selecting rows i'm
going to preview the first five rows
of my sales data set again and as always
since i've been speaking for
55 minutes straight i'm going to need a
little sip here
okay so we talked about selecting
columns using square bracket syntax
we can also select based on rows based
on these index labels and we can select
them either by the label
or by the position all right so what do
i mean by that what is the difference
well the label in the context of an
index that has
a text is the actual value right here
for example 98 cosine here right
i can say give me the row that has an
index level
label of 98 quotient alternatively i can
target the row by the position that it
occupies within my data structure
this is the first row which means it's
given a position
in order in line of zero
that's a big point of confusion for a
lot of people new to programming
in programming we start counting at zero
instead of one
but otherwise the logic works the exact
same way as
as you might count something in real
life so we start at zero this row is
zero
this row next is one two three
four etcetera all the way to the bottom
so we can reference a row either
by its name by the index label or by the
position of the row
amongst all of the rows so let's begin
first by name
so on sales i'm going to use a special
accessor
it's not quite a method it's not quite
an attribute it's actually something
called a property we don't want to worry
too much about it
but i'm going to do something called loc
which is basically short for location
i'm going to provide a pair of square
brackets and then what i'm going to
provide here
is the index label of the row that i
want to extract
so let's say i'm looking for the video
game of wii sports i'm simply going to
enter it here
it's going to identify it in this
collection of data
and it's going to return that row's
information to me as a pandas
series so somewhere in this collection
of 16 000 rows
there is a name of wii sports pandas is
going to locate it within a couple
milliseconds
and give me that rows respective values
as a series right here all right
if i want to target a specific
value in a cell a a value at an
intersection of a row and a column well
then i also have to provide
a column right so wii sports is my row
i can also provide a comma here and a
second
argument a second value of the column
whose value i want to target
so for example if i provide something
like platform this is going to give me
the single value that sits at the
intersection
of the wii sports row and the platform
column
and that is going to be we makes sense
the platform is we
because that's where we sports came out
on all right
it's important to note that pandas data
frame
indexes support duplicates
that is something that makes it distinct
from something like a python dictionary
which
must have unique keys so for example if
i search for a value
like grand theft auto
right here you're going to see there's
actually multiple entries for grand
theft auto on different systems right
different platforms
so because this value matches multiple
index labels
it's just going to extract all of the
ones that match so you can see how easy
it is
to query for rows based on something
like a basic name criteria
with syntax like this all right and this
is just a brand new data frame and on
this data frame we can continue our
manipulations whether it be
invoking methods extracting series
etc all right if we want to do multiple
values
what we can do is use loc and provide a
list
as my first argument so for example i
can say i want wii sports
and i want to also get the rows with
grand theft auto 5
so that's going to get me all of the
index labels that match that
and of course if i want to provide
columns i can provide either a single
column name here like platform
or i can provide a list so maybe
platform and maybe let's try global
sales
and that is going to give me a new two
column data frame it's going to extract
the platform and global sales column
values
for the rows that have a label of either
wii sports
or grand theft auto 5. all right
let's move on to filtering
filtering meaning extracting a subset of
rows
based on some criteria being
met so let me give you an example here
let's say i want to find out all of the
games on this list
that have a publisher of square
enix square enix is a popular company
they make all of the rpg games like
final fantasy
maybe i want to see all of the games
that they have on this list how can i do
that
well i could set it as something like
the index and use the method that we
just saw above
but pandas supports a lot of simpler
ways to
extract rows based on that condition so
i know i'm going to need to target
values in the publisher column
so i'll begin by targeting that column
here it is and these are the values here
these
these are the actual company names we're
keeping the original index
labels of the video game names so what i
can do
is actually compare every single value
here
in my publisher column with a given
string with a piece of text
so i'm going to provide two equal signs
that is the python equality operator
and i'm going to check for the string of
square enix so once again a lot of
people
are surprised by how elegant pandas is
because they might be saying
how can you possibly find a quality
between a column
and a piece of text but remember pandas
is smart enough to realize that
what you're actually trying to do is
compare this piece of text of square
enix
to every value in my publisher column
so what it's actually going to return
here is going to be a series of booleans
trues and falses false means that the
string or the publisher is
not equal to square enix and true means
that it is
so right now all we see is falses but
somewhere in these
16 000 rows in the middle they're going
to be a bunch of trues
so what i can do is this i can copy this
code right here which is generating this
boolean series
i can write my original data frame put a
pair of square brackets
and then paste the code i have above so
within the square brackets after sales
we pass some kind of boolean series like
the one we see output below
pandas is going to find the true values
and it's going to keep
only those rows that have a true
so now we're going to be able to see the
231 games
that have square enix in the publisher
column right right here
let's see here okay so uh uh
kind of a alternate syntax for this that
a lot of people like to use because this
gets a little bit
crazy with all these square brackets is
they like to assign
this boolean series to its own separate
variable
like square enix and because this is
just a reference to
a valid boolean series you can simply
pass in
square enix into the square brackets and
that leads to a little bit more of an
elegant
bit of code same result same exact
output just a little bit
cleaner to read all right let's do
another example we saw previously that
action games were the most
popular let's say i want to find all of
the action games in this list
once again which column do we want to
target we want to target the genre
column
so let's do sales genre
let's see which values are equal to
action we're going to get a
a series of booleans i'm going to assign
this to a
variable called action game so action
game is storing a boolean series
and what do i want to do i want to take
sales and i want to pass in my boolean
series represented by
the action game variable and now you can
see we're going to get
all of my action games notice here in
the genre column every values action
much like every value in the publisher
column right here
is square enix
okay next up what if we wanted to
combine
both of these results what if i wanted
the games that satisfied
both criteria they must both be
published by square enix
and they must be an action game not
either or but both so what i need in
programming terms is an and
operation two ands true and true two
things must be true
in order for um this to be extracted
publisher of square enix
and a genre of action so what i can do
here is write sales
and i have my square enix boolean series
what actually what i can actually do is
provide
the ampersand symbol that's shift 7 on
your keyboard
and then provide another boolean series
after my
and symbol so i'm going to provide
action game
so what this is saying is look across
both of these boolean series
and only where a row has true in both of
these
should should the row be extracted and
kept so now we're going to get
a data frame
of all video games that have a publisher
of square enix
and a genre of action so if i scroll
down you can see it's quite a list
but it's actually not too big there it
is i'm scrolling all the way to the
bottom
and to the top all right so this little
ampersand
means and both this and
this what if i wanted either or
what if i wanted either published by
square enix
or an action game and keep in mind
something that satisfies
both of those criteria would also be
included that's just a logical
kind of common sense thing if it's
either or and it satisfies both
conditions it's also going to be
included
so what i can do is copy the syntax from
above square enix
and action game but i'm going to replace
the ampersand with a vertical pipe
that is the or operator so what this
means is
give me all of the rows from the sales
data set the sales data frame where the
publisher
is square enix or the value in the genre
column is action
or both so if i scroll down you're going
to see
a whole bunch of values here here you
can see the publisher is not square enix
but the genre is action similarly
somewhere in this data set are going to
be rows
where the publisher is square enix but
the genre is not
action those are going to be included
here as well but we're going to be able
to filter
uh very very quickly here all right
that's a kind of a big part of
panda's power is how quickly can kind of
cut and dice and slice and dice this
data set
all right so right now we've been
comparing text values what if we want to
do something with numbers for example we
have our global sales column here
what if i wanted to find all video games
that had global sales
above 10 million well what i want to do
is compare
each one of these values to a value of
10. i want to see
if they're greater than 10 because if
they are i know they've sold
over 10 million copies well just like we
saw broadcasting earlier with plus and
minus and multiplication and equality
we can also do something like the
greater than operator
so i'm going to write 10 here again
pandas is smart enough to realize here
that what we're telling it is
look at all the values in the global
sales column and identify the ones
whose value is greater than 10. so we're
going to get a boolean series i'm going
to assign this to a variable like
over 10 million
and then if i take a look at over 10
million by passing in that boolean
series in square brackets
we're going to see we're going to get a
list of the really high selling games
that have sold a ton of copies globally
over 10 million
all right there's a lot of these really
powerful
filtering operations that are built into
pandas let me give you another example
up ahead
so let's say i wanted to find all of the
games that have
a year between 1991 and 1995.
right so i could in theory use my and
operator and create two boolean series
one saying that the year must be greater
than 1991
and one saying that the year must be
less than 1995
and pull the and operator and make that
happen but there is a convenient method
available called between
that does that for us so what i'm going
to do is reference my
year column i'm going to call the
between method
and this method takes two parameters or
two configuration settings
it accepts the lower bound the starting
point and then
the upper bound to the ending point so i
want to go from 1991 to 1995.
that's going to give me another boolean
series so i can assign this to a
variable like
early 90s game and then below
sales early 90s game
passing that bullion series and now we
can see all of the 484 games that came
out between 1991
and 1995.
all right cool so that's part of the
filtering there's a lot more
options and tools of course available
and slicing and dicing text data in all
kinds of different directions
booleans numbers etc
but of course we just are flying through
here trying to show you a lot of what
the library can do
very quickly let's talk about aggregate
operations
these are very common mathematical
operations that you may be
curious about and i just want to show
you how easy it is for you to calculate
certain things in pandas for example
here i have my global sales column
let's say i wanted to find the average
so i wanted to find the average number
of copies that
a game has sold on this collection on
this data set
there is a method available called the
mean mean is just the synonym for
average
and you can see right here it's 0.54
million copies there is also
methods for things like sum so if i ever
want to sum all of the sales
in the global sales column
you can see it's 8 820 million
um copies of total video games sold on
this list so video games are obviously a
very lucrative
uh industry similarly on any numeric
series such as global sales
or anything else in our data frame
there's a max method so now you can see
the game that sold the most it has sold
82.74 million copies
and similarly there is a min
which will tell you uh the minimum so it
looks like there's some video game on
this list that barely sold
uh anything all right the next thing i
want to show you is probably the most
complex thing it's called
a group by all right so here's the the
data analysis puzzle i want to throw
your way here's what we're trying to
find out here
let's say i wanted to find the sum of
global sales
which we saw above for the whole column
but let's say i wanted to find it
per genre okay so
in our genre column we have something
like 12 unique values
what if i wanted to find the total
global sales for
sports for role playing for
miscellaneous for a platform
so the really kind of redundant
excessive way to do it
is to create a bunch of boolean series
and filter down
to 12 or so data frames for each of the
unique values in the genre column
but obviously that's not very scalable
or sensible because there could be a
hundred different genres
what we need to do is group the values
in the genre column
based on a commonality right i want to
take all of my sports rows and put them
into a common group
i want to take all of my platform rows
and put them into a common group
and then once i have those groups each
one storing the respective games for
that genre
on those groups i want to take their sum
okay i'm going to show you how easy that
is to do in pandas it's literally two or
three lines
the first thing i'm going to do is call
a method called group by
on my data frame and i'm going to
specify which column i want to create
the groupings from
which column do i want to look for
values in and then segment rows
based on those columns values so of
course i want to target
my genre column
so this is going to give me an output
that is not fancy at all but it's a
special object called
a group by object i'm going to assign it
to a variable here called
genre group
and what i can do is take genre group
provide square brackets and reference
any one of my existing numeric columns
from my original sales data frame so in
this case i want to target
global sales so i'm going to target
global sales
and by itself it doesn't give us
anything but on this group by
object which is a series group by i can
invoke the sum
method so it's kind of confusing and
tough to explain but
what we're doing here in a short two
lines of code
is lumping together all of our genres
into separate groups into separate
clumps into separate buckets
then for each of those genres going to
the global sales column
and calculating the sum of all of the
records of all the rows
belonging to each of those individual
genres
so what we're going to get here is a
series and we can see the sum
of all of the games belonging to a genre
of action
is 1722 million
total global sales so in just two lines
we
have aggregated right we have
manipulated aggregated grouped
and performed an analysis perform the
sum analysis
in just two lines of code and now we
know
uh the total sum so if we want to find
out the
if you want to sort this for example if
we want to find out which genre did the
best
remember this is a valid pandas object
this is actually
a series object it's a one-dimensional
data structure
but it also supports a method like sort
values
so if i do sort values and right now
it's in descending order but let's say i
want to make it in
actually it's in ascending order now
let's say i want to make it in
descending
here i can see that action does best as
the most sales per genre although there
are
a lot of titles for that genre in
general you can see sports does well
after that
followed by shooter followed by role
playing
all right we can get you know pretty
nitty-gritty here we can similarly find
things like
the average
right here so we can find the average
number of sales
per genre by taking all of the video
games belonging to action
and taking their average this is what we
get pandas repeats the exact same
operation
for every other unique
genre in my genre column in my sales
data frame all right let's close this
night off with one more example
this is something that's a little bit
more uh
fancy but it's something that i'm a big
fan of it's called melting
what i want to do first is take a look
at sales
and what i'm going to do here is i'm
just going to bring
this name column back into the fold
back as a regular column into my data
frame to do that i'm going to use the
reset index method
here it is i like this so i'm going to
keep it by providing the in-place
parameter
and giving an argument of truth so there
are two ways to store data
and i always that's not that i get them
confused but i always uh
i always i'm scared of saying the same
name twice because there's a lot of
different
uh synonyms for the same thing there are
wide data sets that stretch out
and there are tall data sets that
stretch
down the way
that a data set grows is dependent on
how data is being stored
inside of it so this is an example of a
wide
data set or at least some of the columns
follow a wide data set
so i want you to focus your attention on
these columns right here on the right
hand side
if you think about it these columns
fundamentally represent
the same variable it's the same piece of
varying information it's the sales
right it's just that each column header
is also specifying
the region right we have north america
europe japan other sales
so if for example we were to introduce
an additional region tomorrow like
australia right or antarctica
that additional column of sales would
cause the data set to grow
wider it would require additional
columns to be added on to the right
right we can
you know we would have na sales then
we'd have japan sales then we have
you know a new column of australia sales
right
so it's growing wide and sometimes wide
data is good because it's good for
getting a quick summary for example i
can know immediately that this video
game of 98 koshien
this is how much it's sold in each of
these regions however
there is a different way of storing data
that makes it a lot easier generally to
manipulate and that is um
toggle data tall data grows down so if
you think about it there's fundamentally
two pieces of information that are
stored
in all four of these columns or the
values in them
it's the actual sales number and it's
also the
region itself so because the region is a
distinct
varying piece of information it does
vary
we may not have the that perception here
but it's true
it's varying because notice we have the
same fundamental value of sales in each
column
what's varying is the column header but
these
values of north america europe and japan
are
categorically in the same bucket they
represent the same thing they represent
a region of the world
so we can have an alternate structure of
the data that looks like this i can have
a region column right
and then a sales column right next to it
and if i just take something like my
first row of 98 quotient
i can take a region like north america
and its sales are 0.15
and then a region of europe for the
exact same row
and its sales are 0.10 and a region of
japan
and its sales are going to be 0.12 so
this is an
alternate way of storing these columns
data but notice that this data is going
to grow down
if i added another region like australia
or antarctica
this data set will proceed downwards all
right and the reason i tend to like this
structure more
is because each column is actually
storing one piece of
variable information and it's kind of a
value belonging to what the column
header is
this is an example of a sales number
this is an example of a region
in comparison the presence of a value
here it does represent
the sales number but it is specifically
its presence at a given
place that indicates that it is a north
american sale
so the column header is kind of hiding
this variable piece of information
uh that is differing and we're simply
repeating columns
in this approach we have taken that
varying piece of information of region
and we've kind of isolated it
which is why i tend to like this format
more and the last thing i want to show
you tonight
is how to go from a data set that looks
like this to a data set that looks like
this
and by the way we can do the process in
reverse i think we're more used
to going from this to this because
the process of going from this to this
is what we call a pivot table in excel
right we are aggregating uh based on the
values in a
in a given row we're setting some of
these values as either the rows or the
columns
we're taking the sum or the average of
another column hopefully you're all
familiar with pivot table operations
and that's exactly what we do when we go
from something like a tall data set to a
wide data set
but what about the reverse what if our
data comes in like this
and we want to get it into this shape so
here's what we do
we have a method available called melt
and this is going to be the most complex
method of the night we're going to
provide
a couple parameters the first one is id
vars
and iv vars is basically going to be the
columns that we'd like to keep so kind
of the identifier columns
that don't particularly have any
relevance or importance as far as
um moving or shifting things around so
for each row the values that are going
to stay constant irrespective of whether
we're storing our data like this
or like this is for example going to be
the name
and let's throw in let's say the
publisher
all right next up and i'm going to break
this up across multiple lines so it's a
little bit easier to read
the next parameter here is something
called value vars
and value vars is going to represent the
columns
that i want to move into this
uh tall format so these are the columns
that have uh
that belong to the same bucket that
belong to the same category
so it's these four columns right here
it's these four
sale columns that are still
fundamentally all sales columns they're
still
holding the same variable piece of of
information that floating point number
that represents a video game sale
so that's what i'm going to provide here
those four column names and a sales
eu sales jp sales and other sales
i'm not going to include global sales
just because it's kind of an aggregate
column in itself
all right and if i execute this that
is it we're going to take all of these
records
and we're going to create actually four
rows for each video game
right because each row is now going to
each video game is going to need a row
for
north american sales a row for european
sales
a row for japan sales in a row for other
sales
so you can see right here we're going to
begin with 98 caution that's our very
first
entry right here and we're going to get
its value
from the n a sales column which is 0.15
and it's going to repeat that process
for n a sales for every single
video game then it's going to repeat the
same logic for eu
repeat the same logic for jp repeat the
same logic for other sales and you can
see towards the end here we're starting
to see
other sales so you can see here the
number of rows has drastically ballooned
it's now 65
000 because we have four rows for every
original video game
right however what we've uh increased in
terms of the
height we're significantly taller we've
also decreased as far as the width right
because there's a lot less columns here
because they're now
kind of condensed into these two columns
if i want to modify these columns names
i can so for example instead of variable
i can call it region and instead of
value i can call it sales
let's see here it's going to be value
name
first mistake in 90 minutes pretty good
almost made it to the end
didn't quite make it there we go so now
we have a region column specified here
and a sales column specified here and
this represents the melted
version of our original data frame to
melt
basically means to unpivot to do the
opposite of pivoting
to take something that is essentially an
aggregate or
categorized set of data and then bring
it back
into a a single grouping so we've taken
these four columns and we've now put
those four columns into a region column
and each one is storing their specific
sales it's a lot easier to go from
this type of data to this type of data
it's a lot easier to find for example
the total sales or the average sales
with a shape like this
um compared to one like this all right
so that is melting it's a little bit
more of a
not the most popular operation but
something more complex that hopefully
shows you some of the powerful features
of the pandas library so we went through
some of the basics
some common everyday operations like
filtering and broadcasting and then
something a little bit more on the
advanced side all right
so we are nearing 90 minutes we are
nearing our end that's all there is to
cover here i just want to say thank you
again for
joining me um if you are curious to
learn more about pandas as i mentioned
there's
two wonderful resources i can recommend
to you
you can pick up my book pandas in action
available from manning.com
if you go to manning.com dotd
you can get it for a 50 off for the next
four hours
otherwise it's pretty inexpensive um
it's gonna be published in book form
next year you can pick up an early
access copy uh so you can start reading
it today
see it as it's updated and then get the
print copy when it comes out early next
year um manning is responsible for this
twitch channel and for putting this
little tutorial together so big kudos to
them thank you to them
and again if you prefer text that's
great if you like your
tutorials in video format i also have a
video course on udemy called
data analysis with pandas in python very
similar to what we just went through
except instead of me rushing through
what we just did in an hour and a half
that much content would probably take
something like three or four hours so
this course moves a little bit slowly a
little more slowly
a lot more baby steps uh a lot more
examples a lot more repetition
a lot more friendliness if you are
unfamiliar with python
if you're coming to this straight from
excel all good
there's even a two hour python boot camp
in here so you can get comfortable with
the language
so to keep things short if you like your
tutorials in video format
you can also check out my course of
course if you were to ask me
i would recommend both why not have the
best of both worlds video
and text other than that i hope you've
enjoyed this hope you've learned a
little bit about what pandas is capable
of
it's really just excel on story and
steroids plus a whole bunch of other
fancy
tricks and features that we didn't get
into there's a lot of things you can
integrate pandas with like data
visualization
there's all kinds of complex statistical
manipulations you can do
other filtering operations we didn't
talk about things like joining together
different data sets so
things like sql joins left joins outer
joins uh
right joins inner joins all that stuff
working with text data splitting text
identifying duplicates uh categorizing
by rank um
identifying duplicates across one column
two columns
all kinds of different complex topics
that are covered in more detail in the
book
and in the course and in the pandas
documentation if you're curious
so hopefully this has given you a good
sense of all that you can do with pandas
it's a great introduction to programming
it's a great next step in your data
analysis journey
if you're an excel person and you want
to get into something a little bit more
technical
it's a really great step into python and
programming in general it's another huge
benefit is
it's a great exposure to the python
language which is very generalist you
can take python and use it in a wide
variety of domains
beyond just data analysis so i actually
my story is i was a data analyst i
didn't go to school for computer science
i went to a job where i was required to
learn pandas
which led to python which led to me
going to software engineering bootcamp
which led to web development and now i
work as a software engineer
so data analysis led me to pandas which
led me to
my current career so it can be done and
there's a lot of people
who work with excel who actually are
doing programming like things
every day they just don't realize it yet
so pandas is a great bridge
if you are somebody who's a data analyst
who's curious about
uh exploring more about programming it's
a really great bridge really great segue
in to that all right that's all there is
to say
uh thanks for tuning in hope you enjoyed
the experience hope to
see you again sometime soon and uh until
next time
uh panda's on uh best of luck in your
data analysis journey